je suis atteint du syndrome que l'on
appelle le syndrome
de ramsay hunt
comme vous pouvez le voir cet oeil ne
cligne pas je ne peux pas sourire de ce
côté du visage cette marine ne peut pas
bouger
c'est complètement paralysé de ce côté
de mon visage
pour ceux qui sont frustrés pour
l'annulation
de mai prochain concert
je ne suis juste physiquement évidemment
pas capable d'assurer mes concerts
j'espère que vous comprendrez et
je vais en profiter pour nous reposer
donc il annuler 15 dates pour le moment
pas encore les dates françaises pour
ceux qui sont qu'ils ont prise oui
benoît oui moi comme je disais on en
parle avec magali on aimerait bien avoir
le certificat parce qu'ils se défoncent
tellement au cannabis ce que à mon avis
il ya un truc un petit peu des
rochers de et aux grandes marques pour
faire des boîtes de juin déjà roulé il
veut commercialiser son propre cannabis
ou c'est légal dans son monde mais dans
son état la californie il n'avait jamais
parlé à
parler dans une dame en noir se défoncer
comme ça ça se dérègle alors il avait
déjà parlé
[Musique]
ce serait pas calmé depuis qu'il est
avec sa copine et ou qui d'ailleurs sa
femme ou sa contre parenthèse a fait un
mini avc il ya quelques temps aussi
parce que ils me disent on est déjà dans
l'île et ils vivent une période pas
facile mais pas ce qui me semble qu'ils
dormaient dans un caisson à oxygène
alors ça on l'a aussi voilà ce qui se
dit beaucoup c'est que quand il est chez
lui et qu'il ya du monde autour ses
agents ils arrivent dont sa femme à qui
le cam ils arrivent à avoir une vie mais
des qui part en tournée voilà c'était
que les qualités de stone c'est le cas
de britney spears dès qu'ils partent en
tournée qui sont entourés vici c'est
l'acte et vival les mauvaises personnes
autour y arrive ça se décompose et il
faut avoir une vie très saine pour faire
j'imagine une tournée pareil whitney
houston a dû arrêter et là c'est pareil
ils arrêtent d'aider à préparer
psychologiquement parce que sinon on n'a
quand même pas de bol parce que cette
maladie qui s'appelle
l'écran l'autre la paralysie de la
moitié des villas du visage parle pas du
village
c'est un pur 1% combien de huy une sorte
de bactérie en force sur la varicelle
est un peu de zona ont fait ça n'a rien
à voir c'est sûr maintenant toi
je vais très étrange en fait c'est
surtout que ça touche normalement des
personnes à partir de 60 ans donc c'est
bizarre que sa guerre comme si jeune je
ne pense pas qu'il ait fait signer pour
voir mais c'est vrai que je pense pas
que ça puisse avoir un rapport avec la
drogue zona est donc un sauna c'est une
sensation ça vient de la varicelle et
pour finir avec firme l'histoire du
question il est fan de michael jackson
du plus petit qui danse comme michael
jackson comme ça effectivement comme son
idole il avait dit fictivement qu'il
dormait dans la question oxygène salle
aidé beaucoup pour l'anxiété mais pas
pour l'apa pour tous le regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
voilà donc bien et beaucoup attaché de
l'église aussi oui absolument ces
éléments mais comme tous les gens qui
souvent pas être lésé les chanteurs
comme ça tu avais un peu perché tout ça
c'est un peu compliqué quand même
bonjour moi je rappelle quand même que
quand j'ai croisé lewis hamilton le
pilote de formule 1 oui voilà un jour je
lui dirai ce que je peux à et c'en est
un mais deux ne touchez pas il ya que
dieu peut le toucher
qui prouve qu'ils connaissaient pas ils
savaient pas qui tu t'es mignon